[MUSIC PLAYING]
[CHEERING]
SCOTT BRADLEE: Thank you.
So what just happened
here actually
factors into my
whole story of how
Postmodern Jukebox came to be.
You see, when I
got out of school,
and I moved to New
York City, and I
was expecting to try to make
it as a jazz pianist-- that
was my goal.
That was my dream.
And I met with a lot
of failure at first.
I couldn't get a gig anywhere.
I tried some grad school.
It didn't go so well.
And I wound up with $100,000
of student loan debt,
living in a basement,
and having trouble.
I had no gigs or
anything like that.
And then, on a whim,
I just thought,
what have I got to lose?
You know, I know that there
was a lot of, at the time,
amateur musicians using YouTube.
And there was a time that
I believe that I was too
high and mighty, or I was too
good to put myself out there
on the internet like that.
But then I just thought,
what have I got to lose?
And I uploaded this
medley of '80s--
you know, just like we just did,
these '80s hits reinterpreted
as ragtime piano.
And the next day I went,
and I checked my email.
I had expected to get
maybe 50 hits on it.
And then I see just a
long string of comments.
I hadn't figured out how to
disable comments from getting
e-mailed every single time.
So I had this long
list of comments.
And I just check it.
And I see that there's
10,000 views on it.
And then check it
a couple of hours
later-- it's 20,000 views.
And I realized I
just went viral.
And I didn't know
what that meant.
At first I thought, well,
does that mean I'm famous?
No, it doesn't mean that.
It doesn't mean you're famous.
But I did know one
thing, you know,
that that was more
people that had
seen me play as a
result of that one video
than had seen me play live
in all the years of my life
combined up until that point.
So I realized that, if
there was a way that I
was going to make it
into the music industry,
it wasn't going to be the normal
path of playing $100 restaurant
gigs, and sending out
demo CDs, and stuff.
I realized that there
was this other way
to make a career of music.
And that's what I
talk about in my book.
And that's what we're
going to talk about today.
So thank you for
having me, Anna.
ANNA SANTOS: Thank
you for being here.
SCOTT BRADLEE: And
also, I got to admit,
I played the Madonna
part of that for you.
ANNA SANTOS: Thank you so much.
SCOTT BRADLEE: I know
you like some Madonna.
ANNA SANTOS: I do like Madonna.
Scott and I have
something in common.
We spent a lot of our childhood
years listening to records
and making up our own
improvised music videos.
In my case, it was Madonna
and Whitney Houston.
In Scott's case, it
was the grand MJ.
So maybe you could
talk a little bit
about how you started out, your
early years of piano playing,
and what Michael
Jackson meant to you,
and other early influences.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Absolutely,
maybe I'll sit here.
Because I guess that'll
be like-- that feels
a little more natural, right?
All right, that's much better.
These are nice chairs, too--
OK, as I fall of it.
So yeah, my early
years of music--
my first exposure to music--
happened really when my
parents would play me
records, like actual records.
They weren't hipsters.
That was just the
medium of the time.
This was the early '80s.
And then for my sixth birthday
I got my favorite record, which
was Michael Jackson's "Bad."
And I spent a lot of times
just poring over the lyrics.
I learned how to read
as a result of reading
his lyrics, which led to kind
of a unfortunate incident
where my mom had to
try to define the word
"seduce" to me in the most
G-rated way as possible.
And yeah, I learned
some dance moves.
I tried the moonwalk,
which was just
kind of walking
backwards at that age.
That's all I could do.
But it was really a
big inspiration to me
to be able to--
well, first of all, to learn
to read as a result of it,
but also to find a type
of music that I really
connected to when I was a kid.
But then, years later--
I mean, that's when
you're age six.
You know, I was age six.
And I listened to that, and
MC Hammer, and all these guys.
But then I kind of just
fell away from pop music.
And I fell away from music in
general until maybe I was 12.
ANNA SANTOS: And what
happened when you were 12?
SCOTT BRADLEE: So I had
failed at piano lessons.
My teacher dropped me,
because I didn't practice.
I was just not--
you know, she just told
my mom straight up,
"he's not really
motivated to do this.
And you're wasting my
time and your money."
So I stopped taking
piano lessons.
And I was overjoyed at the time.
I didn't like taking
piano lessons at all.
But then, no sooner did I stop,
that I heard a piece of music
called "Rhapsody in Blue."
And then it was just
one of those moments
where I was like, wait
a minute, piano doesn't
have to be this boring thing
with scales and sonatas
or whatever.
And George Gershwin, the
composer of "Rhapsody in Blue,"
had a really seamless
way of integrating jazz
and classical music together.
So I knew what
classical music was.
I didn't know
anything about jazz.
But when I heard it, I just
fell in love with the sound.
And I decided that I
was going to figure out
how to play that sound.
And I started going
to the library,
and taking out cassette tapes,
and just putting it by my hear,
and trying to figure out
what all these great jazz
musicians were doing, and really
just a lot of trial and error.
I was from a small town.
There was jazz piano teacher
that I could go to for help.
And this was kind
of pre-internet,
so you had to do it
the old fashioned way.
ANNA SANTOS: So you're
largely self-taught?
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
ANNA SANTOS: That's amazing.
SCOTT BRADLEE: But
it was really great,
in some ways, that I didn't
have too many distractions.
I think, if I grew
up with internet,
you know, it's a
distracting thing.
There's all this
fun stuff to do.
And even learning something
can be overwhelming,
even learning a skill.
Like you look--
"how to play jazz"--
Google that, and you're going
to get it like so many results.
But for me, the only
way was to listen
to what other jazz musicians
had done and were doing.
And that's kind of the tradition
of how that art form grows.
ANNA SANTOS: Right,
and you describe
in the book that vintage music
was a way for you to escape
some of the teenage
angst, and loneliness,
or social isolation that
you felt. So talk to us
a little bit about
that and that kind of--
the escape and catharsis
that it gave you.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Well, I mean,
we all remember high school.
I think for everybody, high
school is like a crazy time.
Or I mean, in my case, I
think even like eighth grade,
seventh grade--
you know, that's the time--
that was when I was--
I grew to the same
height that I am today.
I stopped growing at
like eighth grade.
But I was like 110 pounds.
So my ears were huge
and all kinds of stuff.
ANNA SANTOS: Parts of your
body grow faster than others?
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah, exactly.
So those years are
a very awkward time.
I have the photos to prove it.
ANNA SANTOS: We all do.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah, yeah.
And for me, I think that music
really serves as an escape.
Because you're very confused
about everything in life,
you know?
You're trying to fit
in with your peers,
but you're also trying to
establish your own identity.
You're trying to break
away from your parents,
but in like a nice way.
You still love
your parents, but--
ANNA SANTOS: But you want to
establish you independence.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Exactly.
So for me, I kind of found
that in practicing piano
and studying jazz.
And whenever I played piano,
whenever I sat at the piano,
it's almost like I went
into this other world
where I'm just connecting
with this tradition of all
these pianists from
1920s New Orleans.
So it was kind of like a
very cathartic experience.
I think I used the
word cathartic right.
I think that that's
how that works.
ANNA SANTOS: Yeah, I mean
it's a romantic notion
to sort of allow yourself to
go back into these bygone eras
that you don't necessarily
fully understand.
But there's kind of this
escapism and daydreaming
quality to them.
SCOTT BRADLEE:
Yeah, I definitely
felt like I was an old soul
and that by doing that,
by learning that
kind of music, I
was connecting
with the generation
that I should have been born in.
ANNA SANTOS: Right, I
can relate to that a lot.
And so that kind of
took you into this group
of social outsiders or misfits
within your high school.
And you quickly showed them
your number one party trick,
which was?
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah,
so I was really
into ragtime piano
and early jazz.
And you can imagine, if
you're a 16-year-old kid
or 17-year-old kid,
that's not what
other people are listening to.
So all my friends
liked pop music.
Or they liked bands
like the Chili Peppers,
or they liked gangsta rap, and
they like all this other stuff.
So I would do
things on the piano,
like take, similar
to what I just
did in the very beginning--
I would take a song like
"Big Poppa," Notorious BIG,
and turn it into ragtime.
And when I did it
the first time--
ANNA SANTOS: Pretty genius.
SCOTT BRADLEE: --they just kind
of stopped what they're doing.
They were like, "that's amazing.
I could recognize
the song in there.
I could hear that."
Then they were like, "can you
play some Sublime like that?"
I was like, "sure."
You know, so I
demonstrated that.
And I didn't really
think too much of it.
It was just kind of
like a party trick.
But it was a way for me
to kind of share my world
with my friends.
ANNA SANTOS: It sounds like a
pretty good party trick to me.
SCOTT BRADLEE: You
know, it worked out.
It was pretty
cool, I got to say.
But that was something I
kind of put aside, because I
didn't think that was serious.
I didn't think-- no jazz
musicians were doing
that, no real jazz musicians.
So after high school I kind
of abandoned it for a while.
ANNA SANTOS: Except that
there was one other foray
into live music
that you did when
you were still in high school,
the notorious Walmart story.
SCOTT BRADLEE: I begin
the book with this story.
I wanted to start
with my first gig.
And my first gig
was at a Walmart.
And I worked at Walmart.
And I wasn't supposed to have
a gig at Walmart that day.
And because of said
gig at Walmart,
I then got fired from Walmart.
So that was an early experiment.
But my friends
were super into it.
I was just like,
hey, I got this idea.
Instead of just talking about
live music, or talking about--
why don't we make a band?
And they're like, well,
where can we play?
I'm like, well, I got-- you
know, I work at the paint
counter at Walmart.
Nobody goes there.
It's a small town.
It's a paint counter.
You know, let's go set up
all the instruments there.
I got over the PA system.
They had a little phone.
You could talk over
the Public Address.
It was supposed to be used
for actual store purposes.
And I was like,
ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome to
the stage-- you know,
doing this whole announcement.
And we played 15 minutes.
It just got shut down.
ANNA SANTOS: I think some of
the people in this audience
will appreciate your band name.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah,
it was Scott Bradlee
and His Intergalactic
Purveyors of Funk.
ANNA SANTOS: And you debuted
with Sly and the Family
Stone, which is hilarious.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah,
some of the classics--
some of the classics.
ANNA SANTOS: So,
moving away from music
for a second, another area
that you've dabbled in and been
successful in is video games.
And you started out--
well, when you were a
kid, one of the things
that occupied a lot of
your time and energy
was tinkering with gadgets,
and pulling them apart,
and disassembling them.
And I think a lot of people in
this audience here at Google
will relate to that.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah, the only
thing is you guys-- probably
when you take things apart,
you can put it back together.
I couldn't.
So it was just like a fun--
I was always very curious
of how things worked.
And I guess later I
started applying that
to music in terms of
just songs, and kind
of pulling parts of songs
away from each other
to figure out what
makes up a song, what
makes up a certain sound.
That's how I learned
to play piano.
It was really hearing something
and then reverse engineering
it, in a way, a process that
I'm sure you guys are all
familiar with, figuring out the
essential parts of something,
and what parts are extraneous,
what parts are just
somebody being creative,
what parts are necessary.
ANNA SANTOS: Right,
and you went on
to do music for
"BioShock Infinite"?
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah, and
that was my first-- so,
as a result of that
medley where I went viral,
and I did the
ragtime '80s thing,
I got a call from a
dude that was like,
"hey man, I really
like what you're doing.
Do you think you could do
that for a video game?"
And I was just shocked.
Because I had never done a
real gig like that before.
And I remember they were
saying like, oh, well
what would you charge for
this, or something like that?
And I'm like, "um, well I gotta
ask my manager, and my agent,
and also my publicist."
I didn't have any
of those things.
I was just a--
ANNA SANTOS: Fake
it 'til you make it.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah, exactly.
There was a lot of that.
But I wound up
working on this game.
And at this time, I had
been doing viral videos,
like piano stuff.
But I never worked
with singers before,
mostly because I was kind
of annoyed by singers.
I just felt like they were
messing up-- no offense
to the singers here, no
offense to the singer I'm going
to bring up in a little bit.
But I was like, oh, they're just
going to mess up my piano part.
But then they found
this amazing singer
there was a Motown
legend, really.
She's sang on all these
old Motown records.
And her name was Miche Braden.
And we put together a--
I did this arrangement
of "Tainted Love."
And it was kind of a
1920s style, Bessie Smith
version of it.
And Miche Braden came, and
she sang the vocal on it.
And, as I was listening to
her sing to my arrangement,
I just had chills all over.
And I just realized this is
what I'm meant to be doing.
I don't have to
be just a pianist.
I can be a producer as well.
And I can bring other people
into this kind of vintage world
that I was dreaming of.
ANNA SANTOS: Right, and
that was the very beginning
of your music collective.
SCOTT BRADLEE:
Absolutely, that was
kind of where I got the
idea to explore that route.
ANNA SANTOS: Would you
like to do another song
or continue with the story
of the birth of Postmodern
Jukebox?
SCOTT BRADLEE: Well
that kind of actually
segues nicely into how
that influenced what I was
doing on YouTube at that time.
I had a few subscribers from
doing these viral videos.
I think about three
of those viral videos
were "Jersey Shore" influenced.
I don't know why.
I'm from Jersey.
I grew up with some
of those people.
It's just the way it is.
I was throwing a bunch
of stuff against the wall
and just seeing
what would stick.
And I started doing a
lot of musical mash-ups
and also genre
mash-ups, like taking
two things that maybe
didn't belong together
and putting them together.
And one example was I heard
that the band Nickelback was
supposed to play at a halftime
of a Detroit Lions game.
ANNA SANTOS: Everyone's
favorite band--
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah, and
the people of Detroit
were so enraged by
the mere suggestion
that Nickelback was going
to be playing in their city
that they decided to create
a petition against it,
and not just any petition--
a Change.org petition.
ANNA SANTOS: So
you know it's big.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah,
so I heard about this.
And I just thought
to myself, well,
I think that there's a way
to make both sides happy.
What if I came up with a
Motown tribute to Nickelback.
So I got a bunch of
friends together,
and we recorded-- you know
this is super last minute.
I'm still in my basement.
I'm living in the basement.
I had a crazy landlord who
you'll hear about in the book.
ANNA SANTOS: Who brought you
quarts of split pea soup--
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah,
she was very maternal,
but she would do
it in a weird way.
She'd be like, "Daniel"--
she called me Daniel.
Because she didn't
remember my name.
"Did you get the
chicken I left for you?"
And I'm like, what are
you talking about, Agatha?
She's like, "I left you chicken.
It's on your air
conditioner outside."
I was like, I was
gone for this week.
So there'd be rotting
chicken outside,
or there'd be like giant bags of
like 200 bagels just molding--
ANNA SANTOS: She
meant well, though.
That was her way
of showing love.
SCOTT BRADLEE: She
showed a lot of love.
Yeah, she was very sweet.
She's a very sweet woman.
And I got everybody
together in this apartment.
We recorded it
super last minute,
the day before Thanksgiving,
and put it online.
And then we went
viral in Canada.
So it still counts.
ANNA SANTOS: Canada
still counts?
SCOTT BRADLEE: You don't get
to choose where you go viral.
But in this case, we
went viral in Canada.
And we got a call to play--
I got a call from a live
nation booking agent.
And she was like,
"hey, so do you
think you could do a whole--
I'd love to have a Motown
tribute to Nickelback
perform at this festival.
Can you do a whole set?"
I'm like, hey, well
we're not a real band.
You know, we only
do that one song.
And she's like, "yeah, I know.
I know, but could you
learn a whole bunch
of Nickelback songs?"
And I'm like, I could.
But then I had this other idea.
I was like, well, you
know, I got this thing
that I do with turning
all kinds of songs
into jazz, into all these
old fashioned things,
and I bring a bunch of singers.
And they're like,
"actually we're
just looking for
Nickelback songs.
Thank you very much."
So that was actually
when I pitched
the idea of Postmodern Jukebox.
But instead I got turned
down, because they just
wanted to hear Nickelback.
ANNA SANTOS: So with the
Nickelback Motown tribute done,
tell us about how Postmodern
Jukebox came to be,
that first moment, the first
video in your apartment.
SCOTT BRADLEE:
Well what happened
as a result of the
Motown Nickelback fiasco,
or whatever you would call
it, a lot of things happened.
I started to realize
that, by bringing singers
in that are really talented
and collaborating with them,
that I could have a
lot more success than I
could have on my own
just playing piano
or something like that.
And then the creative
aspect of it,
doing something that
was unexpected-- it
was similar to playing
music in Walmart.
Nobody really expects
that to happen.
So I realized that I could
do the online version
of my Walmart experiments by
taking songs that you wouldn't
think would work in a genre, and
putting them into that genre,
and then just seeing
how people react to it.
And I actually want to
bring a guest up for this.
So we have-- this is one of my
favorite singers in the world.
And she's toured with
Postmodern Jukebox extensively.
She's been in lots
of our videos.
And she's just an all
around awesome human being.
I want to bring up to
the stage Sara Niemietz.
[APPLAUSE]
So the whole idea behind
Postmodern Jukebox is taking
things that you wouldn't imagine
in one style and turning them
into something else, imagining
how some of the biggest hits--
or, in this case,
you just a random--
SARA NIEMIETZ: Medium hits--
SCOTT BRADLEE:
Yeah, medium hits--
how they would sound
if they were recorded
in a completely different era.
And the thing is
that I think maybe
people that aren't musicians
don't recognize that it's not
so much about playing--
you don't set out to just
to learn one genre.
When you're a
musician, you really
just learn to be a musician.
And you learn to kind
of move between genres.
And just because a song is
done in one way on a recording
doesn't mean you can't take
it into other genres as well.
SARA NIEMIETZ: I
think that's the case
with a lot of
well-written songs, too,
like the Pokemon song.
SCOTT BRADLEE: There you go.
SARA NIEMIETZ: You know, it's
very clear what it's trying
to express, whether it's--
SCOTT BRADLEE:
Gotta catch 'em all.
SARA NIEMIETZ: Yeah, and it
really translates across genre.
And it's very melodic.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Absolutely.
And Sara, maybe you
can speak on this too.
As a singer, what
goes through your head
when you're interpreting?
Because you're not
just singing a song.
And what I love about you is
that you never sing it just
like a recording or anything.
You put your own spin on it.
You put your own personal stamp
on everything that you do.
And maybe you could just
tell us a little bit
how you approach things as a
singer, whether with Postmodern
Jukebox or with your own
stuff when you're interpreting
somebody else's song.
SARA NIEMIETZ: I think,
like Scott, you grow up
listening to so many genres.
When I sing something
that's country, or jazz,
or whatever it is,
I don't really go,
OK, I'm going to try to think
what does this sound like.
It's just so integrated into
your mind and your heart
just from having listened
to so much of it.
Listening has been a really big
part of my musical education,
like you with the cassette.
I had a little Hit Clips
players, and the old iPod,
and all those.
But really for me, when
I'm singing something,
whether it's the Pokemon
song, or it's "Lush Life,"
it's all about the message of
the song and the feeling of it.
So I always start
with the lyrics
and what it's trying to express.
And then I think, if your mind
is in, in the emotion of it,
it's going to come out,
regardless of the genre.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Absolutely.
Yeah, well said.
Awesome.
All right well, Sara, I'll
let you take a little break.
SARA NIEMIETZ: Yeah, that was--
talk about catharsis.
That was intense for me.
SCOTT BRADLEE: It felt good.
But I'm going to bring you
back, so don't go too far, OK?
Sara Niemietz, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]
ANNA SANTOS: So I'd like to
backtrack just a little bit
to that first moment that you
really made it on YouTube.
I think a lot of
folks in this audience
here will be curious
to know how you
grew your following on YouTube,
maybe some tips and advice
that you'd give to young
artists looking to do the same.
And I specifically
wanted to ask you
about a line in the book
that really stuck out for me.
When you were recording that
video, the thrift shop video,
in your New York apartment, and
Robin, your singer at the time,
said, "don't worry.
I'll be fine doing this.
It's only the internet.
It's not real life."
And I'd love to know,
thinking back on that now so
many years later,
and with the success
that you've achieved
under your belt,
where is that distinction?
Is there a line still between
the internet and real life?
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah, that's
a really good question.
And yeah, it's a great
observation, too,
that that line is kind
of blurry in a sense.
There's a sense that
we still don't think
of the internet as real life.
I know that, for me, when
we played our first show,
I didn't think that anybody
would show up there.
It was Toronto.
And I just thought to myself, I
don't know anybody in Toronto.
I see that we have
videos that are popular,
and people write,
and everything.
But it doesn't hit
you as a real thing.
I'd never really met any
Postmodern Jukebox fans
in real life that I
didn't already know.
So to go to Toronto and
then all of a sudden
see that there's a whole
audience full of people,
and they're dressed vintage.
At first I was
thinking it was like--
I heard all these
cheers and stuff.
I'm like, did they book a
famous DJ here or something?
Like what's going on here?
And then I saw they were all
dressed vintage, with bow ties
and flapper dresses.
I'm like, oh, nope,
they're here for us.
OK, let's do this.
But that's when it
felt real for me.
Because I saw the actual--
ANNA SANTOS: The
physical presence--
SCOTT BRADLEE: --the
physical presence.
But that doesn't mean that all
the YouTube stuff wasn't real.
The YouTube stuff is what
gave us a fan base that
was all over the world.
In the old days, you'd have
to play your immediate area,
geographic region.
If you're in New York City,
you play in New York City.
And then maybe you can
branch out and go to Philly.
Maybe you can go up to Boston.
Maybe you can hit
another city around you
and expand your radius.
But with YouTube, you don't
have to do that anymore.
When we started touring,
we did our first US tour
and our first European
tour at the same time,
in the same month.
We had as many fans,
even more fans,
in Prague than we did in the
United States, which was crazy.
So I think that that line is--
I'm kind of answering
your questions backwards.
But I think that that line--
is it kind of blurry?
I mean, it kind of exists
only psychologically.
For some reason we
don't think of things
on the internet as real.
Certainly we all craft
identities online.
When I post a
picture on Instagram,
I'll post a picture of me on
stage or doing something cool.
I won't have a picture
of me like eating oatmeal
in my boxers and spilling said
oatmeal all over my bare chest
or something like that.
ANNA SANTOS: I mean, who
knows how many views you
could get with that post.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Maybe I
should be doing that stuff.
I don't know.
But--
ANNA SANTOS: You never know.
There's an audience for
everything, I've learned.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Exactly.
Yeah, I learned about
that Instagram Bread Face,
where she does this--
she puts her face on bread.
I don't understand it, but she's
got way more followers than I
have, so can't judge.
Internet is a weird place.
ANNA SANTOS: It sure is.
SCOTT BRADLEE: So
that part is for sure.
So then, going back to
the thrift shop video,
that was the first video that we
made where we went super viral.
We got a million
views in a week, and--
ANNA SANTOS: Incredible, yeah.
SCOTT BRADLEE: We were
not expecting that at all.
Thank you.
ANNA SANTOS: Right,
and you became--
on day two, you were the
third most watched video
on all of YouTube, which is--
SCOTT BRADLEE:
Yeah, it was nuts.
And it was--
ANNA SANTOS: --mind-boggling.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Because
we see like a thumbnail.
And it's like Pitbull
and then Beyonce.
And then it's like
us in my living room.
And I'm just thinking,
wait a minute.
That didn't feel real.
That totally felt very surreal.
I'm like, am I the
only one seeing this?
Are other people seeing that?
That's crazy.
And Robin, who was
our singer, she
was my girlfriend at the time.
And she had sung karaoke.
And she never really performed
or anything like that.
But I knew she had
this great voice.
And I had been pushing
her to sing more.
And she just was always
thinking like, oh no, I'm
not good enough to do that.
I can't do something like that.
So then finally,
with "Thrift Shop,"
we had been just
jamming on that.
And I'm like, we
gotta record this.
And she's like, "well, who
do you want to sing this?
You work with so many
awesome singers."
And I'm like, I want
you to sing this.
And she's like, "I don't
know if I'm ready for that."
But we wound up doing it.
And we recorded it.
And it went fine.
And she felt good about it.
And I put it online.
And I kind of braced her.
I was like, this
video is really good.
It might get like 10,000
views, which seemed like a lot.
But I was wrong by
a factor of 100.
And the next day,
the first thing I did
was got a call when she read
like a bunch of comments
and everything.
She was in tears.
Because of all the
positive comments,
there was a few
negative ones as well,
like anything that
becomes popular.
She was like just
really distraught.
She felt like she
ruined the video.
And I was like, no, you didn't.
You did the opposite.
I mean, you just
made this go viral.
This is a million views,
or this is on pace
to get a million views.
But I was trying to
be very supportive.
So I said, do you want me
to take this video down?
You know, if it really
bothers you that much,
I can take it down.
And she was like,
"no, no, it's OK.
Leave it up."
And I was like,
phew, that's good.
Because I wasn't
going to take it down.
There was no chance I was
going to take that one down.
ANNA SANTOS: So I think
that's a good segue
into another question
I had for you,
which was, rising
the way that you did,
in a forum like
YouTube, and becoming
an internet band before you
became an IRL, in real life
band to some extent, how have
you, or what kind of advice
would you give to people on how
to deal with online trolling,
and bullying, and
that kind of thing?
I know one of your
tactics has been
to respond to comments with a
free coupon for chicken wings.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Not
just chicken wings--
it was boneless chili lime
chicken wings from a store
that--
you know, the coupons had
expired maybe 10 years ago.
It sounds disgusting
to begin with.
ANNA SANTOS: But
I love how you did
that, because you were
basically like, well,
no one can retort to this.
Like who has a comment
back to a coupon?
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah,
I mean, I don't know.
I'm not the best example.
I have fun with the
haters sometimes.
I just write funny things back.
And I don't know.
It doesn't-- I'm not somebody
that gets bothered that much
by it.
But there are other people
that do get bothered by it.
And unfortunately
cyber-bullying is a huge thing.
And it's this new problem that
never really existed before.
And there are people that--
and it's not what people
think of as internet trolls.
You know, it's not just one--
you know, I think
everybody expects
it to be a 14-year-old
in a basement somewhere
or something like that.
But it's not.
I mean, all types of people
can be internet trolls.
But first of all,
you have to realize
that you're doing something
right if you're getting trolls.
Because that means you're
creating engagement.
And engagement is such an
incredibly important part
of building a brand, or
building a band in this case.
If you don't have
engagement, if you
don't have a conversation
going, then what you're doing
is not really
connecting in the way
that it should in order to
take things to the next level.
So it's a really
good problem to have.
I mean, it's a weird thing
that, as artists, artists
seem to get an insane
amount of criticism.
And it's funny that you
can put something out--
like all we're doing is trying
to entertain a bunch of people
and make them smile.
And people write like
the meanest things
or just the weirdest things.
One of my early--
my first video that went
viral, I got the comment,
"you're amazing at that piano.
Too bad you look like
such a douche bag."
[LAUGHTER]
And I'm like, all right,
well that's what this is.
All right, so you
have to get used
to being roasted or whatever.
ANNA SANTOS: Right and,
like you say in the book,
once you have haters,
your followers just bond
together that much more.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Absolutely.
It kind of strengthens
the overall community
of the people that
do support you.
Because then they see
almost like-- it's
like they perceive a threat.
And then they band together.
They just kind of
circle the wagons.
I think that's how
you use that analogy.
I'm not sure.
I believe what they do
is circling the wagons.
I believe that's
what it's called.
But at the same time,
you know, if you're
somebody that maybe doesn't
want to read negative things,
just don't read the comments.
I mean, there are so many people
which I-- my advice for them,
I think--
the default advice
should just be, just
don't read the comments.
Give out the stuff.
Don't feed into that.
Don't worry about it.
Because criticism
is mostly invalid,
like 9 out of 10 times,
on the internet anyway.
It says more about
the people that
are writing the comment,
usually, than the people that
made the video.
And it's important to have
a thick skin and develop it,
certainly.
But if you're
somebody that maybe
has trouble with
that kind of thing,
then it's better to just
ignore it completely and just
focus on yourself.
Focus on the art that
you want to create.
And I know, for me, I was
very much a perfectionist
before I put that video out.
Before I did that
ragtime '80s video,
I didn't have anything
of mine on the internet,
because I felt like
it wasn't good enough.
I felt like people were
just going to judge me based
on my mistakes or shortcomings.
And in that first video, I
mean, a lot of people did.
A lot of people wrote things
about my piano technique,
or you made mistakes here.
Blah, blah, blah-- this wasn't
that great, or whatever.
And then I realized,
after I did that,
that I had just
wasted a bunch of time
by not putting anything out.
I mean, it didn't
hurt that much.
It didn't sting me that
much to get some criticism.
I didn't really care that much.
And I realized that I was afraid
of just the idea of something
rather than what the actual--
I don't know how
to end that sense.
But don't be afraid anymore.
ANNA SANTOS: You spend
quite a bit of time
in the book going
into that, which
I found to be really
insightful and I
think would be really
helpful and reassuring
to anybody who's kind of setting
out on a creative endeavor.
I really liked how you battled
with those perfectionistic
tendencies but then
found a way to just let
that go and brought
experimentation
into your repertoire.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Right,
well there was a couple
of things kind of at play.
For one thing, all of a
sudden I had some subscribers.
From that first video, I got a
few hundred subscribers, maybe
500 subscribers.
And that was a lot
for me at the time.
I never had people
that subscribed
or followed what I was doing.
So at that point it
felt worse somehow
to know that I was letting the
subscribers down by not giving
them anything than it did to
get criticized for the things
that I did put out
by a few people.
And it was about creating that--
that created a motivation.
That created an urgency
to put things out.
And I do that to this day.
I'll announce something
that maybe isn't even done.
I'll be like, we're going to put
out our next album four weeks
from now.
And then I've announced it.
So I would feel bad
letting people down.
So I got to follow
through with it.
I've got to make it happen.
I got to not get
bogged down by trying
to make anything perfect.
And then the other thing at
play is that what I learned
is that people want
to see the journey.
You know, people don't
care about the failures
as much as they care
about the successes.
And there's a lot of artists
that were big artists.
And not every song that
they wrote is great.
Not every recording or live
show they did was great.
But people still tend to
prioritize the successes,
because life is just
much better that way.
Why would you focus on
the failures of somebody
when you can celebrate
kind of what they've done?
And so I've kept
everything up there
from the early days, some
early experimentations.
There was a video we did with--
shout out to Rook out there,
who has been helping out.
Rook's in the book.
He's a bit of a character.
Talk to him after
the show, if you can.
Actually, his first show
with us, he sold his pants.
He sold merch for us.
And he's just kind of a--
you know, quite a character.
ANNA SANTOS: A guy who comes
through for you every time.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Absolutely.
One of our early videos,
we used to just goof off.
And we did a video where
he was rapping Einstein.
And we did a Kesha cover,
but we changed all the lyrics
to be about the special
theory of relativity.
So just like weird things
like that-- and we kept it on.
It's not on brand,
but who cares?
That's part of the journey.
And those kind of
projects like that
are essential for
people to see, I think.
I think you shouldn't
be ashamed of any
of that early experiments.
And you should celebrate them.
Because we learned
from all that stuff.
And you know, I don't want
to downplay Rook's role.
Because he's also gone on to
engineer some of our biggest
hits, like "Creep," and
"All About That Bass,"
and "Heroes," which played
during the World Series.
So this is all part
of the journey.
ANNA SANTOS: Right, and I think
one of the things you also
mention in the book is how
it helps to not take yourself
too seriously all the time.
So bringing that
levity into the mix,
and doing things that are also
fun and entertaining, and just
a release, is a way to
mitigate that creative anxiety
and pressure.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Absolutely.
I think it's really
important to not worry so
much about upholding an image.
And I think that it's
a dangerous thing
with social media,
as we all want
to present the most curated,
best version of ourselves.
And a lot of times that kind
of strips us of our humanity
and, you know--
ANNA SANTOS: And
your authenticity?
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah, absolutely.
And I think it's much more
interesting for people,
especially nowadays, to see
internet personalities--
or whoever, vloggers,
celebrities, or whatever--
be authentic, and just
be themselves, and not
try to be perfect, but
allow them to have some fun,
to make some mistakes, to do
some stupid things sometimes.
I don't know.
That's what we're-- you
know, we're all human.
ANNA SANTOS: So going back
to your YouTube engagement
and that topic, tell
us about the moment
that you went-- well, first
off, when you started out,
you had one follower,
one subscriber.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah, my mom.
ANNA SANTOS: I think you
can all guess who that was.
Tell us about--
SCOTT BRADLEE: She's a big fan.
ANNA SANTOS: I
mean, she has to be.
Tell us about the moment
that you hit one million.
What did that feel like?
SCOTT BRADLEE: Well that was
definitely a huge milestone.
I mean, getting back to how
certain things don't feel real,
that was probably one of those
moments where I saw the number.
I think I was just refreshing
the page, because we were at--
it was like three to go,
or two subscribers to go.
I'm like, well, I want
to see this moment.
And then I saw it
just so I could
get the screen shot of it.
But it's not like
a life changing--
there wasn't confetti cannons.
There wasn't all these
things like that.
You know, it was--
ANNA SANTOS: Virtual ones--
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah.
Yeah, right?
You know, I was just kind of
probably just hanging out.
I don't think I was
doing anything exciting
when we hit a million.
ANNA SANTOS:
Oatmeal and boxers--
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah,
it was probably more--
yeah, you're right, actually.
It was the oatmeal in my boxers.
It happens.
But--
ANNA SANTOS: Authenticity,
authenticity--
SCOTT BRADLEE: But upon
reflection about it,
I mean, it's symbolic in
that it was a journey,
and that there was
a lot of pitfalls
that came along the way.
Not everything is one
of these, you know--
what do they-- hockey stick
kind of things, you know?
Sometimes you have
little dips, or you
have things where you're
faced with challenges.
And I mean, in the book, I
go into all the challenges we
faced, including one where
it was almost like everybody
that was in the band--
it was almost essentially
like the band broke up,
and I had to rebuild it
from scratch for a second.
ANNA SANTOS: And
how did you do that?
SCOTT BRADLEE: Well it was--
first by taking stock of,
what is Postmodern Jukebox?
I had to answer that question.
Because for a while
I didn't really know.
When I was starting
this out, I didn't even
know what postmodern meant.
I don't know.
I never looked it up.
I just thought it sounded cool.
So I had to kind of take stock
of whether this was a band
or whether it was
something else.
And I realized that
it doesn't really
do it justice to be a band.
Because we had-- you know, how
do we explain certain things?
We had all these
different singers that
would come do a video with us.
Were they guests?
Were they regular members?
What was the cut off there?
We had a bunch of
different drummers.
Do I have to bring them all on
tour for that to be the band?
ANNA SANTOS: You even had
a subway band at one point
join you, right, that you
discovered in the New York
subway?
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah, some do-op
singers came and joined us.
So another band
joined us on a video.
A giant seven foot clown
named Puddles joined us
on some videos.
You know, we had
a lot of things,
when we were defining
the live show
and what it was--
when I was trying
to figure all that
stuff out, I had
to answer a lot of
those questions.
And eventually I
found that the best
way to kind of present
the idea of Postmodern
Jukebox or a Postmodern
Jukebox universe
was by putting together these
variety shows that were always
changing, with different
members all the time,
so that it was more like
you're stepping into a world.
You're not seeing a band.
You're seeing an experience.
And by doing that, that
give me the freedom
to take talented people
from everywhere, everywhere
I found-- you
know, where I would
work with somebody
from "American Idol,"
and then discover
somebody that's
singing in a coffee shop
that has an amazing voice,
and start working with them,
and put them on a tour.
And by having that kind of
freedom and flexibility,
I was able to take Postmodern
Jukebox much further than it
would have ever gone if it was
just a simple, quote unquote,
"band."
And that's how we
eventually wound up
being able to send
out multiple groups.
Actually, right now we have
a group on tour over in--
I forget.
I should know these things.
But I think it's like
Portland or somewhere.
Sara, you don't know, do you?
Rook, do you know?
ROOK: Santa Rosa--
SCOTT BRADLEE: Santa
Rosa-- thank you, Rook.
ANNA SANTOS: Northern
California, yeah.
SCOTT BRADLEE:
Yeah, and it's been
very common that we would
have a group on tour in Europe
at the same time that we have a
group on tour in North America,
or South America, or wherever.
ANNA SANTOS: So you
really went from being
a musician, to a performer,
to a music director,
really, of this giant
global collective.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah,
a lot of things.
It's definitely a very
unique type of collective,
I guess you could say, to
work with and to head up.
And because there
was no rulebook,
and there was no guide
of how to do this,
and nobody else was really
doing this exact kind of thing,
we had to kind of
make up all the rules
as we went along, and figure
out what works, and test out
a lot of things.
And it's just a
lot of AB testing.
Try things so many
different ways,
and see what gets
the best results.
ANNA SANTOS: And I think one
of the secrets to your success
has been this openness to
embracing collaboration,
which you talk about
a lot in the book,
going from the
sort of lone wolf,
isolated artist
who is very guarded
with his creative
output to deciding,
no, I'm not going to
be kind of that loner.
And I'm going to
actually open myself up
to the collaborative
efforts of others.
SCOTT BRADLEE:
Yeah, well I think
that there's a tendency, when
something becomes successful,
that the person that is
responsible for the success--
or maybe not
responsible-- you know,
the person that
represents that success
can easily become arrogant
or believe that, well, I
did all this stuff right.
I'm the only one
that can do this.
I need to be doing
all this stuff.
But that's a trap.
That's something
that doesn't work.
And it winds up hurting a
lot of very successful people
if they believe their
own hype, so to speak.
So for me, when I went through
that experience of rebuilding
Postmodern Jukebox, I decided
to really welcome collaboration
in all things and
start operating
in more of a best idea wins
kind of mindset, where I'm just
trying to identify what
the best idea is. d it
And doesn't matter
who came up with it.
And that kind of
mentality has really
helped us get our best to work.
And, as a result, our touring
show improved exponentially.
Because I wasn't a director.
I didn't even know what
blocking meant, when
people say like "blocking."
Or people would ask
me about choreo.
I'm like, I don't know.
Make something up.
There were certain things that
were out of my wheel house.
And I had to accept that they
were out of my wheel house,
and that somebody else can
do a far better job than I.
And that really led to
a lot of breakthroughs.
To be a leader of
something, you have
to be able to recognize
the things that you
can do well and recognize the
things that other people can
do better than you--
ANNA SANTOS: Yep, absolutely.
SCOTT BRADLEE: --and
accept that, and not
let that kind of hurt
your ego or anything.
ANNA SANTOS: Right,
and not insist
on wearing all
hats at all times.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Right.
ANNA SANTOS: Yeah,
bring in a team.
Great.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Just
a few hats, you know?
A fun hat, like a cowboy
hat or something--
ANNA SANTOS: Great,
so Scott, let's
open it up to
audience questions.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah, OK.
Let's do it.
ANNA SANTOS: Susanna has the
box-- or Jeremy has the mike.
SCOTT BRADLEE: What is
that magical contraption?
ANNA SANTOS: It's a
microphone in a box.
It's Google, man.
SCOTT BRADLEE: You guys
are changing the way
we use microphones-- crazy.
AUDIENCE: What's up?
I've been following you
guys for a year or two.
Like, I only found out about
you relatively recently.
But there's somebody who
I've known about for a period
of time since like high school.
Do you know Richard Cheese?
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah,
yeah, definitely.
AUDIENCE: So when I
found out about you guys,
I was like, holy
cow, this is amazing.
Because it's similar,
but it's different.
It's unique.
It's fresh.
It's its own thing.
So I guess my question is, if
you knew about Richard Cheese,
did that kind of amalgamation
or hybrid chimera-type
sound that you knew existed
influence you to try
and experiment and do it
your own, creative way?
Was any of that in the
back of your mind as
these things formed
into Postmodern Jukebox?
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah.
I definitely knew
of his stuff and--
AUDIENCE: And for reference--
Richard Cheese, everybody, is
a guy who does lounge singing.
But he does
contemporary '90s songs.
So he did like Limp
Bizkit, and Nirvana, and--
SCOTT BRADLEE: He's done
like System of a Down.
AUDIENCE: System of a Down--
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah, definitely.
It was such a cool idea, too--
his own interpretation
of that idea
of taking songs and
making them retro covers
is completely his
own and very fresh.
And he's got this whole stage
personality and everything.
For me, I think I came at
it in a different way that--
you know, when I was doing
these early genre experiments,
they were more in the ragtime.
It was more of ragtime piano.
It wasn't really
utilizing vocals
at all when I was in high
school and times like that.
So it actually kind
of developed along
a similar line, which
I'm sure he probably
developed in the same way.
He probably started
out by singing these--
or even like, if you remember
that Robert Goulet skit
that they did on SNL with
Will Ferrell and everything,
it was probably something
similar like that.
I think the difference with
Postmodern Jukebox was,
obviously, a lot of people
had done transformations
before I had.
And the difference with
us was more of just
that we kind of crafted a
whole universe around it.
We took this concept,
and we found a way
to kind of build a
whole world of it
so that we could utilize
different talent,
and bring them into
our world, and make
like an ever-changing platform.
And so I guess that's
where we kind of differ,
but very talented artist.
Yeah, he's great.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: You want to go ahead?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, sure.
So this wouldn't work unless
the songs were also great music
and well performed
that you're doing.
But one thing that
I find a lot when
I'm listening to
your songs is you'll
get 30 seconds into
the song or something,
and then realize what
it is, and laugh.
It's a delight, just as we
all did with the Pokemon song
just now.
Do you think of
your songs as having
this kind of like comedic aspect
as well as being this kind
of like serious, awesome music?
Or is that just me?
SCOTT BRADLEE: That's
a good question.
So I guess I'm definitely
obviously aware that there
is something funny about
taking an Iggy Azalea song
and imagining how
"Fancy" would sound
as a flapper anthem in
the 1920s, or taking--
ANNA SANTOS: Which is
awesome, by the way.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Oh, thank you.
ANNA SANTOS: Yeah.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Thank you.
Yeah, that was a fun one.
Or having a giant sad clown
sing "Royals" by Lorde--
but, when I approached
these songs as an arranger,
I never want it to
drift into parody.
So I take everything
100% seriously
when it comes to the
arrangement process.
So even when we did a Motown
tribute to Nickelback,
it was really important
to me to not just do
like a funny wink and a nod
kind of spoof on Nickelback.
Because I felt that
that was too easy.
And it wasn't as interesting as
raising some actual questions
in people's mind.
People would watch
our video and then
actually pose the
question-- wait,
I liked this version of
this Nickelback song.
Does this mean that
I like Nickelback?
Or does this mean that I wish
Nickelback was a Motown band?
Or does it mean that
their song is so good
that it can work as Motown and
Nickelback at the same time?
So there was a lot of
these kind of like--
[MIMICS EXPLOSION]---- kind of
brain explosion moments when
people would hear those.
And that's because we didn't
want to lead the witness, so
to speak.
We didn't want to
do it as a joke.
parody anything.
We wanted to just do
these experiments.
This is what this
song would sound
like if it was recorded
back then, you know?
ANNA SANTOS: But I mean,
that brain explosion
moment, I think, is the desire
of every creative person,
right?
To create that experience
for somebody else--
SCOTT BRADLEE:
Well yeah, you want
to challenge your audience.
And you want to get people to
think differently about things.
ANNA SANTOS: Defy expectations--
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah, and I
think that any kind of original
work--
and even though
we're doing covers,
we're approaching
it as original work,
in that it gets the same
sensation, that you're
seeing something new.
And it's changing the way that
you think about something.
ANNA SANTOS: Absolutely.
Any other questions
from the audience?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
I want to pass it
down to you after.
Quick question--
so I've heard a lot
about people seeing
your live performances
or your band in whatever
incarnation it is
at that moment performing live.
But you started out as
a completely online,
kind of separate from
the real world, band.
Do you find that performing live
is more satisfying in any way?
Or is it more stressful?
Or do you just take
away different things
from the two different kinds of
ways of expressing your music?
SCOTT BRADLEE: Well
actually, for most of us,
it was actually kind
of the opposite.
With the exception
of Robin, she was
the only one that hadn't
come from the world
of live performing.
And for the rest of us,
we had for many years
been live performers.
And most of the musicians that
I worked with, and singers--
and we had done everything
from bar mitzvah
gigs, to weddings, to
bar gigs at 2:00 AM,
and all these kind of things.
So in a lot of
ways, that gave us
an advantage when
we went to perform
as an internet sensation
going to the stage.
Because we had already had
a ton of stage experience.
And for us, the stage
just felt way better
and felt way more natural.
There's something that's weird
about performing to a camera.
And kind of the
stylistic reasons
that I do the videos in the way
that they are-- usually it's
like a static camera,
and it's very intimate.
It feels like you're just
sitting on a couch in my living
room-- is because I want
to create a very casual
environment for the performers,
where they can feel like
they're playing just--
you know, they're
just jamming together.
ANNA SANTOS: A small club?
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah,
jamming together,
and they're getting the
energy from each other,
since we don't have an
audience to give us energy.
But when you're
in a live setting,
it's more about taking
energy from the audience.
And that's the big difference
between the two genres,
so to speak.
ANNA SANTOS: But the
success of your videos,
considering that they're done in
this really kind of bare bones
environment without fancy
effects and gimmicks,
is amazing.
I mean, it's a testament to
your strengths as musicians.
SCOTT BRADLEE:
Yeah, well we wanted
to put the focus on the
musicians and the music itself.
There's a lot of people that are
doing super fancy videos that
look awesome and amazing.
So we took kind of the
counter-intuitive route.
And that was just do the very
simple, camera on a tripod,
what you see is what you get.
You know, everything
is done live.
We don't do overdubs.
Sometimes there's even mistakes.
Like, I remember talking
about in the book,
there was air conditioner
noise in our first album,
like a ton of air
conditioner noise.
And then, when I
put out the album,
Billboard contacted
me, because it charted.
And they asked me, OK, well
who did your album cover?
Who took the photo?
Because we're going
to run the photo.
So I just wrote back,
"photo by self-timer."
And they're like, "what is that?
Is that a company?
And I'm like, no, it was
the self-time on my camera.
And we just set it on a tripod.
ANNA SANTOS: And the
air conditioner gave it
a nice 1920s crackly effect.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah, kind of.
Yeah, you know, you can spin
all that stuff, you know?
ANNA SANTOS: Totally.
I think we have
another question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Oh, this is cool.
So the songs that
you guys cover,
like a "Royals," versus like
a "Creep," or an "All About
That Bass"-- they're
all really different.
And I was wondering if there's--
are there like songs
that lend themselves
to being transformed into
this like ragtime sound?
Or like what do you look
for musically in songs
when you're deciding
what to cover?
SCOTT BRADLEE: Well I look for
contrast, first and foremost.
And a lot of times that's taking
all the expectation of what
people have when they
listen to a song.
It's taking that, and kind
of flipping it on its head,
and putting it into a
different historical context,
but having it
somehow still work.
So I look a lot at
the lyrics actually
and the overall
structure of the song.
An example would be
"Sweet Child of Mine."
When you pick apart all--
you take away Axel Rose.
You take away Guns and Roses,
take away all the guitars.
It's just a folk song, really.
Like it's written as verse.
Then there's a refrain.
Then there's another
verse and refrain.
So it's a very old style song.
And even the lyrics of it,
"oh, sweet child of mine"--
you can imagine it being
done as an old blues song.
So when we did it, we
got that same singer
that I've worked with
before, Miche Braden,
from "BioShock Infinite."
And she recorded a
Bessie Smith style vocal.
And when you listen to it, it
changes the context of the song
completely.
But it still works.
It's just a different song.
Now it sounds like maybe
it's like a mother singing
to her child in
1920s New Orleans.
ANNA SANTOS: Yeah, beautiful.
SCOTT BRADLEE: So that's when
we're able to kind of-- when
we're on the money--
and it's not possible
to do it every song.
And we don't always nail
it every single time.
But when we do, that's
usually the result. Actually,
I'd like to try it.
Can I try this little box--
can we trade?
All right, you sir.
AUDIENCE: OK, I apologize
if this was already asked.
I had to step out at
the start of Q and A.
But you seem to be like
one of the dream successes
for YouTube.
Were there any unnecessary
hurdles or barriers
that it seemed YouTube put
in place towards that success
that maybe my
disallow other people.
SCOTT BRADLEE:
Well, actually I'm
trying to think of
where to hold this.
Be careful what you
wish for, right?
No, you guys can hear
my like this, right?
OK, all right.
ANNA SANTOS: Welcome to Google.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah.
Well, I think not just
YouTube, but pretty
much every social media
platform-- you know,
they're dynamic platforms.
They change.
And the algorithms change.
And there's a whole
copyright issue that
changes with all of them, too.
For a while, YouTube
was kind of the Wild
West in terms of publishing.
Everybody was doing
covers, but they
were like technically illegal.
Because that's a
whole other thing.
And then Facebook, of course--
they didn't have content ID.
So there were
publishing companies
that were just issuing
take-downs of everything
every time you put something.
So you kind of had to adapt to
all these changing conditions.
And a lot of the--
in the music
industry especially,
the technology has accelerated
at leaps and bounds,
while the legal side
of it has not at all.
And that's--
ANNA SANTOS: Like in
many sectors, yeah.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah, absolutely.
And even the idea of doing
arrangements as an arranger,
I can't copyright
my arrangements.
So there'll be a
reality TV show that
will take an arrangement of
mine and do it note for note.
And there's no recourse other
than going online, and being
like, hey, WTF, you know?
So there's a lot of
issues in that we're just
navigating in a space that
isn't really well-defined yet
in terms of legal aspects.
And then, of course, I
mean, like anything else,
all these platforms
are going to change.
You know, I'm sure that, in
five years or 10 years, Google,
and Facebook, and
Instagram-- they're
all going to be very
different than they are now.
So you really have to be willing
to kind of ride that wave
and just stay on the board.
I'm trying to use an analogy,
because I saw surfboards
outside.
So I figure that's a way to
reach the young kids at Google
or something.
I'm going to go
switch mikes back.
Yeah, thanks Rook.
You want to try this?
Try this out.
AUDIENCE: I've used them before.
You can throw them.
It's pretty cool.
SCOTT BRADLEE: What, really?
Throw it to the next person.
AUDIENCE: Oh, watch your head.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Hey, that
was almost a lawsuit.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for
coming, by the way.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: I'm a big fan
of a lot of the songs.
And so I imagine,
similar to some
of the stuff you
were talking about,
some versions actually work a
lot better than other versions.
And so do you have
some lessons you've
learned along the way about
which versions that you've done
seem more successful?
SCOTT BRADLEE: Well I guess
that's a-- that can be tricky,
because you're dealing with
a lot of factors in terms
of how you define successful.
Some people would define
successful as having
the most views, for instance.
But we know that--
I mean, yeah, we know
that that's not the case.
Because there are
some things that
have a lot of views that you
wouldn't really call successful
or whatever.
So I guess the bigger
question would be,
when I'm approaching
arrangements,
or when I'm approaching
making content or videos,
is there something that I can
do to have it land more the way
that I intended it to land?
And yeah, I think that
there is in that I
think that I've found
that you need to always
be kind of changing
your environment
or changing the frame
around something very often.
And we always try to
kind of experiment
with the type of
videos that we do.
We don't just
stick to one genre.
We do lots of different genres.
I think the one we put out last
week, or this current video,
is a '70s fuck thing.
We don't do a whole
lot of '70s funk.
But it was really
fun to arrange--
I love that style.
So it was fun to
arrange in that style.
And we also cover
things that maybe people
wouldn't expect us to cover.
We covered Baby Metal one week.
And there's only a
few people probably
in this room that are as big
of Baby Metal fans as I am.
But if you guys don't
know, it's a J-Pop group.
And it's these three girls
that combine J-Pop with metal.
And it's amazing.
You've got to look it up.
Their big hit is
"Give Me Chocolate."
And I'm not making this up.
It's crazy.
And then, when you watch Baby
Metal, then go watch Lady Baby,
which is two J-Pop singers and
then an Australian wrestler
that--
yeah, it's crazy.
ANNA SANTOS: You have
an encyclopedic mind.
It's staggering how
much is in there.
SCOTT BRADLEE: I spend
too much time on YouTube.
I don't even remember
what the question was.
I just kind of went out on
a rant about Baby Metal.
But no, yeah, I've definitely
learned a lot about that.
And the other big
thing is learning
about the editing process.
Sometimes we'll start something.
And then I'll realize,
even when we're recording,
that it's not working.
It just isn't landing
the way that I
thought it would in my head.
And you have to be willing
to scrap everything
at any point in the process.
And that's the way to kind
of get your best work.
If you hold on to something that
isn't working just because you
felt like you put some time
into it, that's a bad move.
Don't think of it as
cutting your losses.
Just think of it as
editing, like anything else.
ANNA SANTOS: Flexibility is key.
SCOTT BRADLEE:
Absolutely, absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Which pieces
are you most proud of?
SCOTT BRADLEE: In
terms of arrangements?
Jeez, I'd have to
think about that one.
That's a tough one.
I don't know.
You know, I'm grateful
for the successes.
I'm definitely grateful for the
ones that were the big hits.
But there's definitely a
bunch that were lesser known,
or maybe didn't
get as many hits,
that I felt like my
work was stronger in it
as an arranger and everything.
I don't know.
I'd have to think about that.
Or I'll just say I love
all my children equally.
[LAUGHTER]
ANNA SANTOS: Your mom
would be so proud.
SCOTT BRADLEE: I'm
proud of them all.
AUDIENCE: Speaking
of your mom, you
mentioned she was your
first subscriber on YouTube.
I've always wanted
to ask someone
who kind of hit the top
of their dream industry--
what are the types of
conversations you had with her,
and-or other members of your
family and friend circle,
as you started hitting
these surreal milestones?
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah, well
I did talk about that a lot
in my book.
And my mom is like
the ultimate mom.
She's such a mom.
I don't know how other to
describe it, that she's
very mom-like in her demeanor.
And she came to my book
release show in DC.
We just did one.
And I brought her on-stage,
because I wanted her--
ANNA SANTOS: That's sweet.
SCOTT BRADLEE: --to talk
a little bit about--
and she was a little nervous.
And she walked into the piano.
And then she blamed
it on the fact
that she drank a little
bit of the punch.
It was this whole thing.
From her perspective,
nothing's really changed.
The whole thing
is kind of weird.
You know, when I first
got a gig at a restaurant,
like a steady gig
at a restaurant,
she was just so proud.
And she was like,
this is perfect.
This is the gig for you.
And then, when things
started taking off,
she's like, ah,
that's a bit much.
You know, like, why
don't you just go back
to playing in the restaurant?
She's still pushing me to
go back to grad school.
I'm like, mom, I'm not
going to go to grad school.
She's like, it's going to
look so good on your resume.
I'm like, what resume?
I don't need to do this.
She's like, if you ever
want to teach at a univers--
I'm like, mom-- you know?
But she's a mom.
And I'm very grateful for that.
Because I think
it's very important,
when you're experiencing
any success, to have
people that keep you grounded.
And that's why a big part of
the Postmodern Jukebox family,
essentially, is
made up of friends
that I've known since I was in
college or even high school.
So I brought them
along for the ride,
and not just along for
the ride, but I have them
as my trusted gang of people
that can tell me if something's
good or if it's not.
Because I know that I'll always
get an honest answer from them.
ANNA SANTOS: They'll
be real with you.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Exactly, exactly.
And that's the same thing that
you want from your family.
I'll just say that there
was one funny thing that--
one story about my mom--
she came to one of the shows
that we did in New York City.
And afterwards people were
taking pictures with me,
but they also wanted to
take pictures with my mom.
Because I had called
her out during the show.
So she was posing for
a lot of pictures.
And she didn't really
know what to do
when she's posing for pictures.
So somebody got a
picture with her.
And then she started
asking them questions.
And saying like, "oh,
where are you from?"
And "that's a nice
suit that you have.
Are you a scholar of some sort?"
And the person just was
like, "hey lady, I got to go.
I'm sorry, I got to get
pictures with the other cast.
I got to get a
picture with Hailey."
ANNA SANTOS: She
sounds really earnest.
SCOTT BRADLEE: And my mom
just said afterwards--
she's like, "I felt so used."
And I'm like, oh, poor mom.
Sorry, mom.
ANNA SANTOS: Mom,
welcome to show-biz.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah, exactly.
AUDIENCE: Hi again, Scott.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I just
want to apologize.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Thank
you for making me tea.
That tea was delicious,
the best tea I've ever had.
AUDIENCE: It was terrible.
I tried it afterwards.
I was so flustered
the entire time.
SCOTT BRADLEE: No, don't
be down on yourself.
It was perfect.
It was really great.
AUDIENCE: OK, good.
You're such a prolific musician.
And I was wondering, out
of the numerous artists
in your very diverse
catalog of covers,
has anybody that you really
admire reached out back to you
and said, hey, I really
liked your version.
That meant a lot to me.
I think covers are beautiful,
because they're kind of--
it's returning
someone's art to them
in the same form in
which you received it.
And so I was wondering if
there's anybody that you really
hold dear to your heart who had
any words to give back to you
that really meant a lot to you.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Well I can
tell you about the first time
it happened.
AUDIENCE: Did
Nickelback say anything?
SCOTT BRADLEE: I was just about
to say, when we put that out,
and somebody tweeted the link
to Nickelback, and either
Nickelback or a representative
on their behalf--
I'm not sure who runs
their Twitter account--
just wrote back "killer."
And that was it.
ANNA SANTOS: That's
all you needed.
SCOTT BRADLEE: But no, we've
had a lot of great endorsements
by the artists.
And that's always
been fun to hear,
to hear somebody that wrote
a song and appreciates
what you did, and
how you changed it.
And one of our earliest
ones was Beyonce.
She put up a video.
She shared our video
on her Facebook page
and just wrote "love this."
And all of a sudden
we had all these--
ANNA SANTOS: That's
pretty phenomenal.
SCOTT BRADLEE: And it
was a great endorsement.
It was very early.
It was right before
we started touring.
And it was a great endorsement
to have at that time.
So yeah, we hear from
a whole bunch of them.
And that makes it kind of funny.
Lorde said that her
favorite cover of "Royals"
was the version we
did with Puddles.
So that was--
ANNA SANTOS: If you haven't
seen it yet, check it out.
SCOTT BRADLEE:
Yeah, so that was--
ANNA SANTOS: Pretty good.
Well, thank you so much,
everybody, for attending.
And thank you so much to Scott--
SCOTT BRADLEE: Thank you guys.
This is fun.
ANNA SANTOS: --and to
Sara for being here.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Yeah,
thank you to Sara.
ANNA SANTOS: It was a
real treat to have you.
For those of you here in the
audience, Scott is based in LA.
I saw Postmodern
Jukebox last summer
at the Greek Theater in Griffith
Park under a canopy of stars.
And it was an electrifying show.
So if you have the opportunity
to see them live, please go.
Because they're amazing.
Thank you.
SCOTT BRADLEE: Thank you, Anna.
That was great.
ANNA SANTOS: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]